[Applause]
[Music]
so the new york times has just published
its list of must-see places for 2019 and
nestled quietly in the top 25
destinations
is none other than the falkland islands
[Music]
we're not talking about a tropical
paradise here we're talking about a
remote archipelago in the south atlantic
more than 700
islands exposed to the harsh elements
with a tiny population of just 3 000
people it's a territory as empty as it
is
inhospitable nevertheless this
wind-blown backwater was the cause of
intense political tension
in the second half of the 20th century
culminating in a
war between the united kingdom and
argentina
[Music]
one thing the islanders have made it
perfectly clear these islands
are british they are the queen's loyal
subjects
they're wishing to stay that way
[Music]
it's important to understand here that
for argentinians the falkland islands is
a national issue argentinian children
learn very very early that the falklands
are a part of argentina for them the
british occupation of the islands was
nothing more than
imperial plundering
[Applause]
[Music]
so given its controversial history the
new york times list sparked a few
questions do the falkland islands belong
to argentina and why are they so
important to
mainland residents after all argentina
is a huge country in fact the eighth
largest country in the world
so why all the fuss about this remote
inhospitable and largely uninhabited
archipelago well
this video aims to answer these
questions but first things first
let's find out how it all began
[Music]
the origin of an endless dispute
the beginning of the 19th century the
spanish colonies in america begin to
protest against spanish rule the recent
united states declaration of
independence and the french revolution
have ignited a desire for autonomy and
freedom that cannot be suppressed
in 1808 the napoleonic invasion of spain
led to the dismantling of madrid's power
and
that kicked off a race towards
independence that more or less resulted
in latin america
as we know it today so it was that on
may
25th 1810 just two years after the
french occupation of spain the municipal
council of the city of buenos aires
decided to replace the viceroy of rio de
la plata
with the first government agenda
argentinians today
think of this as their first patriotic
government argentina was on its own
roads revolution but it wouldn't be free
of spain until six years later
on july the 9th 1816 came the
proclamation of independence of the
united provinces of the
rio de la plata and this is where the
first confusion
[Music]
arises
you see many people think that the vice
royalty of the rio de la plata created
in 1776 by king carlos iii of spain was
synonymous with what we know of as
argentina today but this wasn't the case
let me explain while it is true that the
vice royalty of the rio de la plata
included modern-day argentina it also
included uruguay bolivia and paraguay
[Music]
alright so some of you might now be
thinking well hang on simon where do the
falklands fit into all of this
well the fact is that uruguay paraguay
and bolivia along with the falkland
islands were all part of the vice
royalty of the rio de la plata and the
thing is i don't think you'll find many
argentinians claiming
sovereignty over paraguay bolivia or
uruguay these days
and of course if they did everyone would
think they were crazy
so well why the falklands the fact that
the falklands were part of this mammoth
vice royalty which belonged to the
spanish crown
is not really surprising what is
surprising is argentina's claim
on the falklands especially given that
until this territory was consolidated as
a british sovereignty it was passed
back and forth between european powers
numerous times
[Music]
from hand to hand from play to play
the history of the falkland islands is
actually much simpler and shorter
than many people think
you see until the mid-1700s the falkland
islands weren't even inhabited on a
permanent basis
indeed the first people to live there
permanently were not the british or the
spanish but the french
yep you heard that right it was the
french who first permanently inhabited
the falkland islands but that is
only the start between 1764 and
1833 the islands passed from one nation
to another first from france to spain
then to england then back to spain and
finally
since 1833 the falklands have been under
british sovereignty
[Music]
so let's do some quick addition since
they began to be permanently occupied
the falklands have been under spanish
sovereignty for just
over 40 years and under british
sovereignty for more than 180.
so why does argentina stake its claim
quite so vigorously well it all goes
back to the time between the may
revolution and the subsequent
declaration of independence of the
united provinces of the rio de la plata
at that time the local authorities began
sending expeditions to the falkland
islands which they considered their own
and this is precisely where the
controversy arose
because while the argentinian version
insists that the english snatched part
of their territory in 1833
the truth is that at the time argentina
was still a work in progress and its
borders were far from defined
and if you're not convinced well check
this out just five years before the
british returned to the falklands in
argentina lost uruguay what's more it
took until 1862 that's almost three
decades later for argentina to have a
national
president
in other words in 1833 when the english
regained control over the falklands
argentina's borders were yet to be
decided there was no argentinian
national government and so of course
they had nothing like
a national army in fact it may seem hard
to believe that between
the years 1852 and 1860 the state of
buenos aires wasn't even part of the
argentine confederation
but in the grand scheme of things this
isn't so
extraordinary stories rely on the
continuous changes in rules of the game
viewed through a historical prism
sovereignties come and they go
all the time
now it's clear that history can be
framed and interpreted in many
different ways and that may explain why
many argentinians insist that when the
english reasserted control over the
falklands in 1833 the islands were
already a part of
argentina as we know it today and
therefore are a part of the argentinian
homeland but
let's see because 190 years later can
you guess how many people of argentinian
origin live on the falkland islands
today that would be 18.
in fact there are almost 10 times as
many inhabitants from chile
as there are from argentina nevertheless
not so long ago the contested
sovereignty
was grounds for war
[Music]
an unexpected war
ever since the british regained control
of the falkland islands argentina has
wanted them back
it's been like a national obsession
through the generations
in 1888 they began publishing maps that
included these previously disregarded
islands within
argentina's borders
now let's just be clear that apart from
the map redesign there were no great
claims on the falklands from either side
until the second world war up until then
argentina and england were two friendly
allies
in fact the latin american country that
received the most direct and indirect
investments from england
was argentina
but after the second world war
everything changed for one thing
commercial relations between the
countries were no longer as significant
secondly the election
of general piranhas argentina's
president gave weight to his nationalist
and anti-imperialist discourse
and thirdly the newly created united
nations was focused on the process of
decolonization
in fact u.n resolution 2065 invited
argentina and the uk to clear up the
matter of the falkland sovereignty in
1965. but within two years of this
resolution the situation had taken a 180
degree turn
in 1967 london told the argentinian
government that it was willing to cede
sovereignty over the falklands but
on one condition they had to respect the
wishes of the kelpers or the falkland
island inhabitants
the only problem was that the kelpers
opposed any sovereignty transfer point
blank in fact they actively mobilized
against the possibility by creating what
became known
as the falklands lobby
and it seems that at the time the
british government was willing to
deliver or at least
share sovereignty over the falklands in
exchange for commercial agreements so
let me stress here that it was the
island's inhabitants themselves
who prevented this in the mid-1960s
pragmatism would have probably led the
british government to transfer the
sovereignty of the falklands
had not the falklands lobby arisen to
counter the pressure of argentine
demands
clive ellerby an english researcher
author of the work
role of the falklands lobby and that is
how things stood on april the 2nd
[Music]
argentina
[Applause]
[Music]
on that day a grim military government
led by general leopoldo galtieri held
power in argentina it was a discredited
and
repressive regime without the people's
support and responsible for one of the
darkest periods in argentina's modern
history many citizens were branded
political prisoners and
thousands more simply disappeared and a
huge economic crisis it was crippling
the economy on that day gautieri's
government
made a fateful decision gain the
people's support by feeding
their patriotic further and with that
the argentinian government decided to
invade and occupy the falkland islands
the argentinian authorities expected
this move to spur a diplomatic agreement
with the uk
however they underestimated this woman's
determination
margaret thatcher the prime minister of
the united kingdom was willing to fight
a war
thousands of kilometers away the outcome
well it was disastrous
people of the falkland islands like the
people of the united kingdom are an
island race
their way of life is british their
allegiance is to the crown
they are few in number but they have the
right to live in peace
to choose their own way of life and to
determine their own allegiance
[Music]
the british army's technological and
military superiority coupled with the
argentinian government's lack of
planning they carried out the invasion
with many young poorly equipped and
poorly trained soldiers allowed the
united kingdom to recover the islands in
a little over
two months so once again a tyrannical
government's political decision
ended with a war as unnecessary as it
was useless costing the lives of
hundreds of people
and look we know how sensitive these
types of border issues can be
and with this video we want to put some
facts on the table and maybe give you
a new perspective because throughout
history territories have passed from one
power to another for more than 300 years
what is now argentina was under spanish
rule for more than 180 years the
falklands have been british but what
does it matter
who was and wasn't right 200 years ago
isn't it more important to think about
where we are today and try and build a
more harmonious future
just a little reflection from us a
visualpolitik now here are some more
questions why is there so much
interest in the falklands what's special
about these islands these are topics
we're going to address in an upcoming
video
here on visualpolitik but before we go
we'd really like to hear your thoughts
what do you think should happen to the
falklands comment section should be fun
i really hope you enjoyed that video
please do hit that like button if you
did and don't forget to subscribe for
brand new videos also don't forget to
check out our friends at the reconsider
media podcast they provided the vocals
in this episode that were not mine
also this channel is possible because of
patreon and our patrons on that platform
please consider joining them and
supporting our mission of providing
independent political coverage
and as always i'll see you in the next
video
[Applause]